let's do a little media coverage of what
is going on in martha's vineyard
vineyard first here is whoopi goldberg
of the view
yesterday undocumented immigrants were
put on planes and flown from texas to
martha's vineyard in massachusetts
florida governor
ron desantis said he used his state's
funds to do that that means taxpayers
paid for it and his spokespersons added
that places like massachusetts and new
york should take care of them since
they're the ones inviting them here by
calling themselves sanctuary cities i
get that i i understand what they're
trying to do i get they're tr they're
trying to make a point but it's these
are people you're playing with these are
real live people with children and older
people and you know we can work it out
but if you're going to be a bonehead
yeah who wants to play with you
whoopi goldberg talking about boneheads
you gotta love it okay so just really to
be clear guys it's a democrat
administration so if the fault starts
anywhere it's with biden that's number
one as i said desantis had it in the
budget the florida dems voted for it the
dems in these cities created sanctuary
cities so everything that is supposed to
be happening is happening right now
libby
are they is desantis a bonehead
i think this is actually really a very
smart political move uh people are
complaining that desantis has
politicized illegal migrants here and i
think that clearly the budget
administration had already done that by
saying that the border was closed when
it was
obviously very very open um and this
actually brought um the stories of this
border crisis to mainstream media where
it has been absent for some time people
are ignoring the problems that we're
facing at the border and desantis was
able to
bring them to the fore and i think that
that's uh that's certainly worth this
and it's not a bonehead move at all
americans need to know what's going on
and um the democratic leaders in this
country need to do something about it
they're clearly able to do something
about it when 50 immigrants who aren't
there to clean the homes of the wealthy
show up on martha's vineyard so why
can't they do something about it in the
border towns and border states where
their help is really needed right
exactly as you drive the point home i
mean they already bust them off the
island in basically 24 hours obama did
not open up his 30 acre estate and give
them a quarter of an acre or anything
like that sarah you're in texas the
texas border towns have been overrun for
years um are you upset that the media
has ignored that while suddenly freaking
out about martha's vineyard
yeah it is really frustrating to hear
not just the media but also you know
chicago mayor lori lightfoot and new
york city mayor eric adams all of these
these leaders talk about the influx of
migrants that they have and they just
don't have the resources to handle and
they're talking about 9 000 migrants 6
000 migrants they're talking about
minute numbers compared to the migrants
the illegal immigrants who are pouring
through the borders here in texas you
think eagle pass texas has the resources
to to you know take care of all these
migrants you think mcallen texas has the
resources to take care of all of these
migrants clearly these border towns are
not equipped to deal with all of this
influx and nobody seemed to care until
it came and fell in the democrats lap um
i mean i i will say
i'm glad i hope as you pointed out that
maybe this is a red pill moment for you
but texas has been dealing with this for
a long time and i would also say to
whoopi goldberg you know i would agree
with her that these people are being
used as political pawns i would say that
they started being used as political
pawns by the left for years and years
and years the left have been the ones to
weaponize minorities not just the
hispanics not just the people pouring in
across the southern border but also
blacks and all of the other minorities
that they have been using as political
pawns for so long and there is nothing
that makes that more obvious than the
fact that when you actually
make them
that hold them to the same standard that
they have been imposing on the rest of
us and say you know what you're the one
who wants them here you're the one who's
opened up your city as a sanctuary city
here you go you go ahead and put your
money where your mouth is all of a
sudden they don't want to do that it's
because they have been the ones who have
been for so long had no consequences for
their policies now that they do it
becomes very clear it's unsustainable